corinne fox here at et and we're going
to talk more about her new movie safety
now before you got the role did you know
ray ray's story i had to bring my little
brother to live with me on campus
everyone's family here when i read the
script i was like oh my god i've heard
the story before
the fact that ray sacrificed everything
for his 11 year old brother i'm like i'm
so there
[Music]
even though it's in the middle of a
pandemic you've been busy haven't you
with other shows and other prep and just
work yes
what's really cool is i got to produce a
show for netflix based off my life
yes called dad stop embarrassing me
which stars my dad who's in it it says
return to television which everyone's
very excited about
did your dad ever embarrass you oh my
gosh
really all the time okay just give me
one
good moment uh you know in high school a
high school boyfriend you know
one day he went knocking on his door
with a group of his friends and was like
hey if you mess up
you know you might not make it out of
this but you are his boss for the
netflix show i am his boss
i'm calling the shouts i'm like hey get
there on time we're not gonna forgot to
be late here
i talked to him just recently and he
sent a little message for you
oh no yeah he did hold on career listen
the fact that you are the executive
producer or dad stop embarrassing me
you are actually my boss so i don't want
to get fired
so i want to make sure i let you know
that i love you and you're the greatest
oh my gosh how sweet i i am his boss
but he is my biggest champion he was
like do you know who you are
do you know who you are like he just
thinks um the world
you